have you been thinking a lot about
education lately because i have
yeah so i mean you've produced
educational content that has been seen
by
tens of millions uh you know you've
developed a real
knack for conveying concepts in a way
that people find fun and engaging
uh and right now there's so many
families and parents who are struggling
because their kids all got yanked out of
school and
we're all wondering what the heck is
next um so i would love to hear
what you're thinking well i mean can i
ask you first
like um you know i think that you
probably have a pretty
pretty unique perspective on education
also on
education policy that i probably don't
have
um and and i have a lot of fear about
what secondary education
or like what post-secondary education
looks like right now what do colleges
and universities and community colleges
look like
um you know if we find that we cannot
gather in the same way
and like how do we interface with with
that with the problems that creates
because of course education is like
so fundamental to the foundation of like
all all of it like all of society all of
innovation all of like
progress so post-secondary
many colleges have no choice but to try
and reopen
uh in september because their finances
are constructed such that if they were
to not have a semester they would
go bankrupt and go out of existence
that's true for many many schools
including some high-end schools
there are only a handful of schools that
have these you know
big endowments and even the schools with
big endowments actually are operated in
a way such that it would be ruinous for
them to not
have a fall semester now the big
question is
how can you charge what you're charging
if all of it's online
and a lot of kids are struggling with
this right now where
some kids who have a choice which is not
many of them but
are trying to defer because they're like
hell if i'm going to have my
first year of college be this online
[ __ ] and i'd spend 60 000
for the privilege of attending class in
my jammies and whatnot like
they're not into that which is
understandable
but from the school's perspective
they're like the show must go on like
the school
must open uh and
like many things with the coronavirus
there have been
problems building up in the system for
decades where our colleges have been
doing a lesser and lesser job of
actually educating people or preparing
them for
modern day life or the economy
especially per dollar spent yeah
well so here here the way the numbers
work for the for these colleges
uh if you look at the cost of various
things most consumer goods have remained
relatively stable in price
books electronics clothes like you don't
see the prices going up to the moon
so what are the exceptions to that the
two big ones are healthcare and
education
where healthcare just keeps getting
racked up up and up and up uh
just like higher prices to the moon in
colleges every year like hey guess what
we're
you know four percent more expensive and
then you like compound that
and college now costs two and a half
times what it cost even
then when i went to college right or
when you went to school we're like both
in our forties and we're probably not
that far so
so yeah um so then you if you're a kid
you're like okay i guess college is 50
or 60 000
now you're a family um and then does
that mean that i get paid more on the
way out
no turns out opportunities completely
stagnant and i actually if anything i've
gotten rid of a lot of them
so how the heck do i afford to go i take
out massive government loans and the
government's like don't worry we've got
you
so now we're up to 1.6 trillion dollars
in school loans
and families feel like well i have no
choice but to take it out because
it's college and you know
my kids gotta go the kid's like well
clearly i'm going to college
and so then they they go they get loaded
up with this massive debt load
and from the college's perspective
they've been paid
they don't need to adjust particularly
and they just keep ratcheting up the
price every year
um so if you dig deeper and you say well
why is college so expensive
why is it that it has to go up in price
it's not
professors it's not even facilities
which most people would guess
it's non-academic administrators the
number of non-academic administrators
and colleges have gone up 150
as prices have gone up they just keep on
hiring more
uh administrators yeah so and like a lot
of it's like
like a lot of money is being spent on
sales basically like to like we're
spending money to make money
and that's just increasing and like if
but if you don't i i
was watching a friend of mine go through
this process her kids going to college
and
like she was like i got this huge
booklet from this university in alabama
but the university of montana i live in
montana
so like the local university only sent
us like a tiny little pamphlet and so i
just don't feel like
and i'm like no don't go to the school
that's spending all that money like they
sent you like a hundred dollars of
material
out of the blue with and like you know
chances are like ninety percent of those
are not going to result in
a sale or more than that so like their
customer acquisition cost is going to be
astronomical and that's what you as a
student are paying for
to acquire new customers for the
university go to the school that isn't
spending money
like it's spending money on [ __ ]
teachers not on on sales you know
and so so yeah watching
and and you know people in academia have
watched this happen
and they've been you know comfortable
the whole time
what just watching as school has become
closer and closer to not being worth it
and eventually you get to the point
where it actually isn't worth it anymore
and for a lot of majors i think you're
already there
where it unless you are unless you have
a ton of money you're not
uh like it's not gonna be worth it for
you to go to school
it's not gonna be worth the loans and
like
it's it's such a and it's it's in the
same way as healthcare it's like so
depressing because this is like the one
like one of the fields where it's like
this is supposed to be all about helping
people
and like it should be this like really
great
good public good public service job
but like more and more professors kind
of can't feel that way because of how
much it costs
they're lucky enough to become
professors man because you have all of
these phds who are in like the permanent
postdoc
adjunct hell where they're gonna get
paid subsistence and
there's no future and it's like hey yeah
tough luck like uh you know we just keep
minting
phds and there are no jobs for you yeah
and the and but and that's what's
keeping the level of
like how much professors are uh cost to
university that's what
that's what's keeping it level lots of
professors lots of tenured professors
are making a ton of money
but on average it hasn't increased
because you've got all these
adjuncts and you've got all these people
who are never going to get tenure and
just like getting paid very you know
the basic basic livings or not not even
a full living
like the teaching of students is not the
primary expense at a lot of these places
let's put it that way you know
they're not exactly pouring the millions
into making sure that yeah you know your
kid has some world-renowned expert
teaching them that yeah
it's it's really immoral
uh what's going on and it's in the guise
of like you said like a public good and
a non-profit in some cases
literally public institutions uh yeah
you know
we've really lost our way in so many
in so many respects and education
healthcare i think are like the two
that affect the most people that
everyone can understand the third one
is housing that's the other source of
inflation but it's not as extreme as
healthcare and education in most and in
some places it is but it but still a
huge crisis yeah yeah it's it's
it's not as extreme in like where you
are in montana like there's certain
metro areas where
it's it's as extreme or more extreme yep
yeah and you know
what really frustrates me is i think
that like there's no doubt in my mind
and i've always said this as somebody
who
sort of teaches uh through the internet
i've always said that like there is no
replacement for the classroom and like
that's not what we're trying to do with
crash course
we have no interest in that and i
believe that that there's no replacement
for the classroom
except that like now you have to now now
you're replacing the classroom there's
like no choice because that that kids
must replace the and so like you have to
adjust that statement to say like
there's no system that is as good as the
classroom but there are other systems
and if you're going to charge 60 000 a
year for the classroom
and other people can find ways to charge
six thousand dollars a year
for an education without the classroom
then you lose the classroom
which is the best way to teach people
but you do lose it
like you lost it anyway and uh because
because we had to find a different way
because it just cost too much money
yeah that this is the crisis that many
universities are struggling with right
now and i think that
they're going to be able to bear it for
one season um though a bunch of the
marginal schools will close even now
it's like just like if you look around
the country
thousands of retailers are closing
thousands of theaters are closing
tens or hundreds of thousands of
restaurants are closing i'm sure
hundreds of schools are closing uh not
not the big wealthier ones or the
the major public ones they can stand it
for
one season but depending upon how long
this drags on for
you're going to see more insolvent
schools pretty quickly
because a lot of families are going to
look up and say wait a minute like this
makes absolutely no sense for us to be
paying
this kind of tuition do you have uh
advice for
kids who are graduating right now i say
kids but they're
you know i i mean like uh getting like
this was their last semester of
so like welcome to the job market it's
covered
yeah this is a very hard time to be
looking for a job that is for sure and
so
a lot of it would be around trying to
find any way
in which you can contribute and develop
that may or may not be in the field that
you're thinking of it might not pay what
you want the living situation might not
be what you want
but just as long as you're growing at
all
professionally you should feel good
about it
like don't think oh i i really want to
get into politics so i have to like make
sure it's like
the perfect job in that space like no no
just if you can find anyone that
will give you a chance to lend a hand
just freaking go for it and if that
and that's going to be hard too just
like even that's easier said than done
um so it would be about trying to find
ways to make sure you're still
uh developing in some respect even if
you're trapped at home
for like a while uh you know making
schedules for yourself
like setting goals for yourself that are
achievable uh reaching out to people
even when you don't feel like it because
it's very easy to
become somewhat of a shut-in i think
during this time
for a lot of folks uh but you have to
continue to try and put yourself out
there
uh i don't have great advice one of the
things i will say though is that if you
have time
like you're in better shape where like
if you're a young person
you'll be able to uh have this be
like an early bump in the road but it's
not going to define your whole journey
like that the people i'm most concerned
about are folks where
you know they spent 10 years working on
some
restaurant or bar food truck that now is
like completely kaput
you know like it like that that stuff
breaks my heart because
yeah i'm like you hank like i love
entrepreneurs i love
people who are actually trying to make
something positive happen
and this crisis is going to do a number
on
entrepreneurs uh to a higher level than
if you've got some
corporate job that lets you work from
home yeah absolutely
yeah and it's it's so hard and so
rewarding
when it's working um but when it's not
working
it is very hard to it's very hard to
work through failure um
and like not just while it's happening
but afterward and i think that the
important thing to know is
like one hopefully everybody gets that
like this is no one's fault
well i mean um that like your failure
was not your fault in this circumstance
um but and also that like um
you know that like one of the things one
of the really great things about making
your own
your own project investing in like
taking your money and spending it on
your dream instead of someone else's is
how much you learn and you can take
those skills other places
and you know management bookkeeping like
entrepreneurs do everything and so there
there's a lot
um like i think that they they are good
hires and
and also there are other opportunities
and other futures
and there's going to be a lot of need
for entrepreneurs and innovation
as we find new ways to
operate whether that's about
coronavirus specifically or if it's just
about the world continuing to change
so we need people with those skill sets
we need people with broad skill sets
who are curious and passionate and want
to
make the world better thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you